pam pam pam notamment temps papa qu'est
ce que c'est il ya eu un accident
ou alors tu vas jouer le rôle du noir et
nous allons annoncer aujourd'hui une
leçon de respiration artificielle cette
affreuse d'accord je ne peux pas voir ça
françois oui tu crois que tu pourra le
sauver et sauver kir
le blessé là haut il est peut-être déjà
mort s'est on mais non mais non mais non
quasi mur casimir mon vieux calmer tout
à cannes voilà tiens regarde hangar
nardo te voir pour tu vois il est bien
vivant
aujourd'hui nous commençons il est le
nom de secourisme vidéo casimir tu sais
ce que c'est
oui bien sûr je sais tout à propos du
raccourcissement saccharine
à quoi ça sert à quoi ça sert eh bien le
secourisme ce sont toutes les règles
qu'il faut bien connaître pour donner
les premiers soins à celui qui vient
d'être victime d'un accident rare et
bien sûr oui je sais toujours ce qu'il
faut faire
ah non oui je me sens en courant bravo
casimir c'est une très bonne réponse
c'est vrai la rue mais attention on
penserait main si tu pars chercher du
secours
c'est en général la première chose à
faire si vous êtes avec un frère une
soeur ou un open qui vient d'être
victime d'un accident
il faut vite aller prévenir vos parents
ou les gens qui sont le plus près de
vous une attention ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut partir en courant traverser
la rue où la route comme un fou sans
regarder car votre mission s'est donné
l'alerté
un deuxième accident serait une
catastrophe je savais bien que c'était
le meilleur secouristes aux exagérations
mais il ya souvent beaucoup d'autres
choses à faire
si vous êtes en groupe y en a un ou deux
qui partent chercher du secours
tâtonner casimir casimir zoba mais enfin
casimir calme toi
calme-toi les autres ceux qui sont
restés près du blessé d'affaires
beaucoup de choses il peut arriver un
jour au cours d'une promenade ou d'une
partie pêche qu'un nouveau camarade
tombe à l'eau ça peut arriver vous
évidemment vous allez essayer de le
ramener sur la berge
s'il ne respire plus il faut faire très
vite
vous pouvez vous même déjà le sauver en
pratiquant la respiration artificielle
et d'ailleurs je vais vous montrer
comment ça se pratique et arnaud tu
descends hop là on venait marque une
démonstration mois on comprendra mieux
mais voilà je suis qu'un ami harry klein
gré très attention la méthode que je
vais montrer casey mears et la plus
simple mais il y en a beaucoup d'autres
évidemment
alors donc marque et la victime allongée
trois parties remarquer première chose à
faire vous des fêtes - le col de la
chemise
les poignées elle la ceinture
vous ouvrez son pantalon vous leur
tourner sur le ventre comme ceux ci
dessous un petit peu que j'ai de la
place pour le faire voilà les gens ne
sont bien allongé les bras aussi vous
prenez le bras droit ou le bras gauche
et vous le replier la main appuyée sur
la vendre à la tête sur le côté afin que
le nez et la bouche soit bien dégagée
pour pouvoir respirer vous prenez une
serviette ou un petit plus ce que vous
avez sous la main et vous le mettez sous
le ventre à la hauteur du nombril comme
ceci vous installer sur lui les genoux à
la hauteur des hanches
vous prenez vos deux mains vous les
mettez à la hauteur de sa taille
les pousses de chaque côté de la colonne
vertébrale et l'opération s'effectue en
deux mouvements premier mouvement
expiration les bras tendus vous appuyez
à peine uniquement le poids de votre
corps expiration vous revenez en arrière
l'inspiration vous vous basez sur le
rythme de votre respiration c'est à dire
à peu près 14 à ce soit par minute comme
ceci alors expiration inspiration
expiration inspiration expiration à 6
regarde inspiration ainsi de suite
jusqu'à ce que votre camarade se
remettent à respirer et il ne faut pas
s'arrêter
même si ça dure très longtemps ça peut
durer une heure ou deux qui a compris
arnaud il faut pas te faire relayer par
un camarade si tu es fatigué faut pas
arrêter je veux continuer jusqu'à ce que
ton camarade recommencer à respirer
tu vas essayer arrive facilement vas-y
vas-y
voilà très bien voilà c'est ça vas-y tu
sais très bien que tu n'aime pas trop
trop fort le bois de son corps sexy très
bien les bras sont bien entendu c'est
parfait expiration inspiration à bien en
relation des émirs pas tout compris à
expiration inspiration c'est ça tu
serais capable de faire désigner whey
inspiration pour continuer quoi nos
marines pas à inspiration expiration
inspiration expiration inspiration
[Musique]
et voilà c'est vraiment beau hein avec
une pancarte est un aussi joli brassard
je suis vraiment le meilleur secouristes
du monde salle les enfants emmenés voir
et voir par ici
vous avez vu casimir il se prend pour le
meilleur secouriste du monde
on va aller voir ça de plus près vous
êtes d'accord laissant bruit on va
sûrement vous suivez allez tout le monde
derrière moi
quasi mais qu'est ce que c'est nous
venons voir le meilleur secouriste du
monde
ouais c'est moi disons plutôt que c'est
ce qui est écrit sur ta pancarte qu'elle
n'a pas confiance en moi moi ton
meilleur camarade de classe ont fait que
je me tue n'ai jamais lu acclamé chanté
la chair du chômage brion j'essaie de
vous car elle est ainsi expliqué moi ce
qui se passe bonjour monsieur du snob
casimir est notre ventes en regard et
saint françois ne veut pas croire que je
suis le meilleur sancourt east du monde
peut-être l'accusé voiteur casimir peux
tu nous faire une démonstration tard on
aime bien sûr bien sûr
venez monsieur du snav allongez-vous sur
ce banc je vais vous faire une
démonstration de respiration
artificielle
c'est moi qui dois m'allonger sur le bo
huawei bien puisqu'il y va de la science
et de la justice je veux bien me prêter
à cette expérience
attention il est prudent quand même
ça y est vous êtes prêts relaxez vous
détendez vous vous êtes bien bon
attention exploration inspiration quelle
réaction casimir inspiration mentionnons
le casimir mais casimir arrêt mais
murray tu es fou au monsieur du snop
s'est trouvé mal
vois-tu françois la meilleure qualité
d'un secouriste a c'est de savoir à quel
moment il faut appeler un médecin
or comme je suis le meilleur secouriste
du monde je peux te dire que le cas de
monsieur du snob n'est plus de mon
ressort mais qu'il faudrait vite appelé
un médecin en médecin en état à vic moan
et à casimir
[Musique]